la parole est à notre collègue françois
noël buffet pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
le garde des sceaux
depuis quelques semaines la sphère dit
air cocaïne occupe la presse et
l'information
ce week-end le nom de l'ancien président
de la république est le principal
opposant au gouvernement aujourd'hui
présent dans une grande formation
politique qui l'est républicain son nom
a été mis en pâture dans cette affaire
l'associant à cette histoire
rocambolesque
faut-il rappeler que c'est à la faveur
d'une perquisition dans le cadre de
cette affaire air cocaïne que le juge
d'instruction a eu connaissance de
factures établies au nom de monsieur
sarkozy
saisissant ses factures il a décidé ce
juge doive d'abord géolocaliser les deux
téléphones portables de monsieur sarkozy
et de se faire produire les fadettes de
ses appels téléphoniques pour la période
allant du mois de mars 2013
au mois de mars 2014 force est de
constater une première incongruité dans
cette affaire puisque les faits
reprochés sont des faits qui datent de
décembre 2012 à février 2013 pour la
société perquisitionné première
difficulté
deuxième difficulté nous interrogeons
sur la manière dont les choses ont été
rendus publics
monsieur le premier ministre vient de
dire à l'assemblée nationale que le
gouvernement n'avait pas été informé par
le procureur général d'aix-en-provence
pour la situation concernant la
situation de monsieur sarkozy
simplement il a été informé de ce qui
s'est passé pour monsieur pour la faire
air cocaïne
en conséquence de quoi on en tire la
conclusion que monsieur sarkozy n'a rien
à voir avec cette affaire de quelques
manières que ce soit et on voit ça dans
la presse ce week-end
on ne peut pas manquer de s'interroger
sur la manière opportune dans lesquelles
ces informations sont arrivés dans la
presse il y a donc eu madame le garde
des sceaux fuite voulu organiser en tous
les cas nous connaissons les
circonstances dans lesquelles sont
arrivées cette affaire et nous
connaissons aussi les mesures dont fait
l'objet monsieur sarkozy régulièrement
il faut conclure madame ma question et
au vu de ces éléments puisque monsieur
sarkozy n'est pas lié à cette affaire
je souhaite que vous puissiez saisir
l'inspection des services
sierre afin que soit déterminé
précisément d'où proviennent ces fuites
et que parce que vous êtes la garante
d'un bon système judiciaire pour tous
les fonds concernés y compris pour les
anciens présidents de la république vous
puissiez mettre en oeuvre cette
disposition merci à parler à madame
christiane taubira garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice lui avez la
parole oui monsieur monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur buffet alors si j'ai bien
compris la question consiste simplement
à me demander de diligenter une
inspection par l'inspection générale des
services judiciaires parce que pour le
reste vous avez décrit ce qui semble
être le cours d'une procédure
vous semblez disposer d' éléments
extrêmement précis sans s'être procédure
et d'apprécier et d'apprécier et
d'apprécier ce qui conviendrait ce qui
conviendrait d'en faire je vous dis très
clairement et très honnêtement je ne
chanterai pas d'inspection générale des
services judiciaires parce qu'il n'y a
pas lieu de le faire et je pense que la
conception vous avez de l'institution
judiciaire doit vous conduire en
conscience a considéré que cette affaire
ne mérite pas que l'inspection
judiciaire soit soient mobilisés il est
important que nous prenions des
précautions avec les institutions parce
que ces institutions besoin d'être
renforcée consolidé est aujourd'hui en
particulier ou ici nous allons commencer
la discussion d'un texte sur
l'indépendance de la justice sur
l'impartialité des magistrats
il est important pour nous de veiller à
la solidité de ses institutions
vous parlez d'un d'une poursuite d'un
opposant
mais vous avez évoqué vous-même l'époque
des faits dans l'époque des faits il
s'agissait pas du chef de l'opposition
il s'agissait puisqu'à l'époque il me
semble que votre chef d'opposition cité
monsieur jean françois copé donc il
s'agissait d'une procédure qui a été
couverte dans le cadre d'une enquête
qu'il était qui était qui était
diligentée sur ea cocaïne avec le seul
point commun la même société
par conséquent je vous rappelle
simplement que ce gouvernement qui
veille à ne pas intervenir dans les
affaires personnelles à respecter
l'indépendance de la magistrature a
conforté les partialité voiture
continuera à agir ainsi et il n'y aura
pas je vous le répète d'inspection sur
cette affaire